you can mess it here play with mono play
with yours oh yeah when I was like 11 or
12 I built the Death Star so this is
gonna be this is just child's play for
me I have little to no experience
building Legos probably say I'm a
beginner I have a lot of experience
stepping on them destroying them I'm
gonna be building a bulldozer I have
been tasked with building a multi-piece
Lego set a dinosaur a train and a tiny
house we're back baby we have three and
one Legos I believe I have a dinosaur
without you a robot my box says seven
plus which means it's like 7 to 15
mine is 7 to 12 literally ages 7 to 12
here we go all right first thing about
Legos we opened the bag you have to just
spill it all out good that's good we got
some music right okay so the first thing
I wants me to do is build the guy they
gave them a like one of those drills
which is weird because if you're driving
a bulldozer you don't need like one of
those drills but hey she's unstick
listen Legos are not for the weak
all right Legos for the strong Legos
I've heard those who are aged seven and
above stop grow up I'm building a house
right now is this a race we race none
enough whose hands are meant to do this
oh wait I have very big hands that's a
lie but they're still too big for these
Legos I'm still gonna outperform
everyone's expectations because let's
type it in the big jewel that I am
people don't expect
movin on I am in step number 10 happy
for you I'm on the 31 number ten outages
number ten of the three things which
means I'm basically on the same step as
he of interesting math thing this I
don't wanna fight I do I'm on step three
one step three one six slowly when
you're better than everyone it's hard
you just have to walk out what the
haters does the haters don't they just
don't want you to build what would we
say to the haters wait wait wait wait
you're saying your pants are tight yeah
you stand up real quick and tell people
please show everybody your pants these
are no no these are did you see that
they're not pants pants whatever pants
too tight in the front
what zipper you won yep that's what I
thought this is like really nostalgic
for me like a pretty girl just Yellin be
mean to me I'm just trying to build
Legos and the whole time being yelled at
but that's your problem you know what I
mean all right guys you got the wheels
on mmm-hmm ready Lucy I'm not really
building a dynasty does this look like
other makings of a dinosaur to you is
seriously like what does it look like up
it looks like I'm building another phone
what is what I build a tractor both
thank you how to build a bulldozers
what's it like to build Lego I'm not
gonna help you anymore you're not
alright you haven't helped much at all
so whatever I'm over at Turner
okay this is a powerhouse I really need
your help you serious no this is the
beginning of keyboard and it's shocking
because it's so lifelike
key one boom I looked at you Legos
these are legs these are legs you guys
they stand up I am shocked and confused
these are wings this is so the guy can
fly and he's gonna fly far we're going
back can you get this off for me so this
is my dinosaur but I think it says that
I'm done now what are all these extra
pieces for all right I'm putting the
jetpack with the flames on the guy oh
that's tight isn't it you guys are that
it is it is tight your ashes but I'm
actually not sure how this is supposed
to go because Oh got it it goes the
other way oh wait I'm done that's it I'm
just done
that's that's it I'll wait for you to
finish take your time
I've got nothing better to do did you
know this my friends is the finalized
product hold on okay this is the
finalized profit hold on no he has legs
that can move
he has oh I can move tickets but just
chillin waiting for you to finish hey
how's your daddy start coming it will be
nice if you ever finish
I mean how does it look like I did
pretty incredible
I smashed it it's magic look at my
collection
this belongs yours okay
I think my work speaks for itself you
know I came out here and I perform I
built five things
he built she built this little dinosaur
what I do this in my free time drunk or
sober probably dropped if I would just
like hypothetically build Legos in my
free time that I pathetically I probably
do it both sober and drunk and there it
is
and that in it and there it is the end
good job
[Music]
[Music]